honestly i'm kind of surprised
because he only had one year on his
contract remaining and he said that he
wanted to finish his career in vegas
marc-andre fleury leaving las vegas
releasing a statement through his agent
in fact did this happen just a few
minutes ago it reads
i want to thank all of the amazing fans
in vegas and my teammates for four
incredible years together
you embraced me and my family from day
one and made playing games at the
fortress one of the great
joys of my life we will miss playing in
vegas very much but i'm grateful for my
time in your city
what a classy statement from fleury
again the big news coming in today that
mark andre fleury the beloved goaltender
for the vegas golden knights traded
to the chicago blackhawks happened
earlier on today
kevin martin on this big story joining
us outside of t-mobile arena with more
on flowers departure from vegas
and that statement just coming in truly
a class act kevin
yeah brian a class act and it's really
unbelievable to think that we have seen
mark andre fleury's last game ever as a
golden knight which was the golden
knights game
five loss to montreal in the semifinals
here at the fortress back
on june 22 but as you mentioned the
golden knights made it official
earlier today trading the future hall of
famer the 2020 vesna trophy winner
and the face of the franchise mark andre
fleury to chicago
general manager kelly mccrimmon
addressed the media earlier saying
two factors went into the decision the
first being he didn't think there would
be the same appetite next season for
fleury
and robin leonard to split the net 50-50
and the second being the salary cap
both goaltenders combined for 12 million
against the cap
with fleury entering the final year of
his contract that pays him
7 million annually you know my job is to
try to make her team better and
you know to do that you need uh cap
space to uh
to improve and i know last year being a
cap team if we're going to
uh you know work on any free agents uh
if you're going to improve your team
there's a caps based component to that
that is
uh that is definitely challenging so
those things all tie into the decision
so it appears the golden knights are all
in on goal tender
robin leonard mccrimmon also said today
that he believes robin
is in the prime of his career with four
years remaining on his contract
as for fleury his agent tweeting out
earlier today
that he's going to take this time to
discuss his situation with his family
and evaluate his future in hockey so it
appears there is a chance
that the 36-year-old marc-andre fleury
could be calling it quits
reporting live outside of the fortress
kevin martin eight sports now
kevin thanks robin leonard also tweeting
there are
not many people i've met or played with
i respect as much as flower
100 percent hall of fame guy that i will
miss